good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us at this Town Meeting
I'm Kim Gough crews secretary and vice
president for university life before I
turn things over to president Saladin I
want to take a moment to talk to you a
little bit about the movie format we
solicited questions and we received
hundreds so we've grouped the questions
into a series of themes and the
presentation will address many of those
themes we do know however that the
presentation itself may mean may suggest
that you have other questions we ask
that you do that we fill out the form on
the webpage that allowed you to give
into this broadcast so that we can track
them if we have time we'll answer some
of the questions live but we will keep
all the questions and make sure that
they go to the correct University leader
now after today the co19
led you and Yale today will continue to
be good sources of information so please
check them often and one final note this
meeting is being recorded because we
want to make sure that if people are not
available to see it that they have an
opportunity to do so and with that I'm
going to turn everything over to
president salivate well thank you Kim
and good afternoon everyone I'm very
grateful to be able to connect with all
of you during this unsettling time in
New Haven across the United States
really around the globe we've been
seeing a global disruption at a scale
that hasn't been experienced in
generations in recent months we've had
to alter our lives dramatically to
contain the spread of kovat 19 I know
that many of you have been confronting
the reality that intermediate and
long-term plans have been upended you've
made sacrifices you've experienced
disappointments some of you have family
members and friends who are out of work
and who are worried about supporting
their families
some of you are caring for someone who
is sick or you may be sick yourselves
I've lost someone in my extended family
and to those of you who have also lost
loved ones I'm deeply deeply sorry today
though I believe it is also important to
express my gratitude for the way our
community has come together to overcome
challenges to take care of one another
to take care of our world to the L
community I'm thankful for your optimism
your resilience for your selflessness
thank you for working hard to maintain
the core functions of our University
especially during these challenging
times our staff whether on campus or
working remotely have really kept this
place going a faculty through their
willingness to teach in new ways has
ensured that we continue to educate
students and create knowledge and our
students have worked hard to continue
their learning online
to those of you who are healthcare
workers you're our heroes and I'm
grateful to colleagues across yel who
are coordinating with the city of New
Haven and with the state of Connecticut
as well working collaboratively with
people across our city and across our
state we can support one another we can
share research findings we can share
best practices we can share strategic
planning how to leave we'll get through
this and we'll get through this
especially if we remain a unified yell
in this period of uncertainty I know
that everyone wants as much clarity as
possible about what Yale will do in the
weeks and in the months ahead for the
next hour or my colleagues and I will
address your most pressing questions and
they fall into three themes the health
and safety of our community
preparing for financial challenges and
preparing for getting the campus up and
running well then answer some of the
questions you submitted during the
meeting I have to say though much of
what we're going to talk about reflects
planning than is still in progress so
you have to think of this as a progress
report okay one of the most commonly
asked questions is some version of how
is the university making decisions I
want to share with you some of the key
principles that we use to plan and to
take action first we will act to protect
the health and safety of Yale faculty
staff students and neighbors this is a
first principle all of our actions so
far reflect the fact that we view this
as a public health crisis first
decisions about health and safety made
by the University in the context of Cova
19 will be evidence-based data-driven to
the extent possible to me this is what
universities must do we need to model
what it means to rely on experts on data
and on analysis to decide among options
this really isn't a moment for gut
feelings our decisions should sustain
and advance whenever possible the
quality of teaching and research at Yale
we need to preserve our core mission
our missions that have engaged this
university for 319 years we must take
the long view and how we think about our
human and our financial resources and I
want to be clear we will be educating
our students in the fall we don't know
yet in what manner but we will be
teaching and creating new knowledge the
diversity and excellence of our student
body is a fundamental importance and we
won't compromise the ability to educate
students regardless of family background
this means we need to protect the
financial support that we provide to
students especially those from the least
affluent families
finally the university-wide priorities
that I've been talking about for the
past few years have not changed the
decision-making will continue to reflect
those priorities now what I'd like to do
is move to another frequently asked
question many of you inquired about the
status of Kovan 19 in New Haven and what
Yale is doing to combat it so Nancy
Brown is the gene and David Wallace Dean
of the Yale School of Medicine and she's
here with us so Nancy how is Yale
medicine the Yale Medical School and our
partners at Yale New Haven Hospital
prepared to face down this virus can you
tell us a little bit about their
preparations and the current situation
the outlook for the virus in New Haven
and in the state of Connecticut and
what's it going to take what's it going
to take from a medical and public health
point of view to resume activities on
our campus Nancy thank you Peter
let me start by Framing where we are and
where from once we've come it's hard to
believe but the first case of CO vyd who
is diagnosed in Connecticut on March 7th
and on the left you can see the trend in
positive cases on the top and in the
number of deaths per day on the bottom
in Connecticut on the right you see the
number of kovat 19 patients hospitalized
in our own Yale New Haven hospitals and
as you can see we are seeing a downturn
as well but that at our peak we had as
many of 450 patients in Yale New Haven
Hospital with approximately 70 of those
patients on ventilators next slide
there's been much work at Yale Health
you know medicine and Yale New Haven
Health System leading up to the first
case of kovat and continuing to make
sure that we could care for our patients
safely this included an early focus on
testing and murray landry shown here
developed the first approved viral test
in connecticut and the first test at an
academic Medical Center anywhere
yo health prepared space for patients
and physicians such as Jonathon signer
stood up three floors of the smile Oh
Cancer Center has new intensive care
space for our coded positive patients
and we reduced the number of elective
surgeries and outpatient visits to make
room for these patients we also
innovated to make sure that we have
adequate personal protective equipment
and ventilators next early on we
realized that we needed to coordinate
our research and our clinical responses
to fight kovat across the School of
Medicine the hospital and the University
and so we created the Cova 19
coordination response team are correct
and here I must give credit to Ruth
Montgomery for the naming and today this
includes members of the FAS the schools
of engineering medicine nursing public
health as well as the Yale New Haven
Health System we created a web presence
that could serve as a repository for
research protocols and preprints so that
our investigators and clinicians could
see data as soon as it became available
and investigators at Yale have been
involved in discovery science
understanding the mechanism of infection
and importantly the hosts response as
well as in vaccine development
therapeutic trials and seminal
epidemiologic studies this webpage also
provides continually updated clinical
protocols and these clinical protocols
have been informed by conversations with
colleagues in China Italy Washington and
more by our own evolving experience as
we learn about kovat 19 excellent
we know that the effects of kovat 19 are
more severe in older patients as well as
those who have obesity or diabetes and
hypertension but we have also learned
that the severity of code 19 is greater
in patients of African or Hispanic
descent we've leveraged a wonderful
group called the cultural ambassadors
these are ministers from the Connecticut
AME Church and members of Hunter for
progressive action who have been
advocates for many years for clinical
research to get the word out about the
ways in which we might limit COBIT
infections and how patients can see we
also understand that
distancing and all the measures we have
taken to flatten the curve have
significant effects on the economy and
therefore the long-term health of our
community and Yale economists and social
scientists have been advising local
state and national government on ways to
reduce the impact a group of faculty
from the schools of Public Health
nursing medicine and management as well
as Yale health have been meeting daily
to address the conditions necessary for
reopening one member of this group
Albert Koh is a member of the governor's
Task Force on reopening much has been
written about the conditions that are
requisite and this chart on the left is
one that I find very simple but useful
from resolve to save lives and I think
what you can see from the graphs that I
showed at the beginning that we are
starting to meet many of the conditions
such as the decline in the number of
cases and deaths in Connecticut and
we've also done a lot to ensure that we
have adequate personal protective
equipment many thing takes of issued
reports and we will use these as well as
our own expertise on campus to guide our
plans for reopening in the context of
both national and state guidance Peter
thank you I wrote to the out community
about the two big issues facing us
beyond the immediate health crisis how
is Kovan 19 affecting Yale financially
and what are we planning to do in the
fall
Provost Scott straw ball is leading the
effort on both of these fronts and so
why don't we turn to him Scott why don't
we start with finances thanks Peter it's
a pleasure to talk to you today about
those questions like many of you my
house my household has been impacted by
this a few months ago as my wife and I
alone in our home we now have eight
people living here as my two adult
children and their spouses and their two
children
now I live with us including a three
year old granddaughter turns out Nora is
looking for distraction and one of the
things she likes to do is we every now
and then go for a drive to just get out
of the house for a few minutes
as we come to the driveway she begs from
her carseat that she might have the
opportunity to steer into the driveway
so before you call DCF this is just a
few hundred a few dozen feet before we
reached the driveway and she needs to
make a right-hand turn what we've
realized that she's done this as she
fails to recognize that as we approach
that turn she needs to begin turning the
wheel instead she assumes that she can
begin the turn as the corner is reached
rather than turning it in advance in
some sense this is this is a allegory of
what it is that we're headed for and
what we're trying to manage as we
consider the financial implications that
are now faced by the University we do
not yet know the full magnitude of the
of the turn that we need to make what we
need we do know that we need to start
making that turn anybody who's looked at
the headlines in the past few weeks
recognizes that this pandemic is causing
huge economic impact entire economies of
the world are laying lock down
unemployment rates have now hits 30
million in the United States alone which
is an unemployment rate approaching 20
percent which is the highest level since
1934 at the heart of the depression
financial markets have fallen steeply
and while they have recovered partially
they are still highly volatile and
clearly unknown for future days and
weeks and months the gross domestic
product which is the broadest massive
measure of goods and services in the in
the country fell by almost 5 percent in
the first quarter which was not a full
covered quarter and it's likely to
follow follow still substantially more
in the coming quarter but what does all
this mean for you what is the magnitude
of the curve that we need to make what
is this turn we need to begin to make
and begin to follow those are the
questions that of course we need to
consider and as I answer that question I
would like to consider them in sort of
three phases the first phase being
effectively this year this financial
year between which is physically
20 which began last July and continues
through June of this year then there is
the medium turn term which is
effectively what happens next year and
then the longer term which is what
happens over the next one to five years
as you know Yale has four main sources
of funding these include tuition
fundraising the generosity of our donors
returns on the endowment and clinical
medical services those are the main ways
that we receive and receive revenue and
use that revenue to pay the various
expenses that run the university over
the past few months this just the months
of March and April the unexpected
unanticipated impact of koban 19 on our
budget is approximately 200 million
dollars this is in the form of both
reduced income
anouk ovid specific costs this includes
the refund that we made to the room and
board for students in our housing it
includes a reduced the reduced clinical
revenue as a result of performing fewer
elective procedures in our in our in our
Hospital it includes fewer gifts from
our generous donors it includes the
reduction in sponsored Awards from the
research that's underway in our
laboratories we put up a field hospital
that had a cost we lost revenue as a
result of the summer programs that we
normally have for students that visit
Yale during the summer months as a
result we see a substantial reduction in
our revenues that of course hits
directly to our bottom line the good
news is the university has sufficient
reserves that we can manage this
one-time shock we budget conservatively
and we act prudently and so if this was
a one-time impact we would be able to
easily not easily but we would be able
to manage the beginning of this turn but
we anticipate that this is just the
beginning of the turn there are other
high levels of uncertainty let me give
you just a few eggs
ampuls as we begin consideration of the
FY 21 the fiscal year 21 budget which is
next year's financial budget we can
already see that there will be greater
need for financial aid for our students
there is a significant level of tuition
uncertainty particularly for students
that are from international locations
that may not be able to get to campus
not because of the lack of interest or a
lack of desire on our part but
challenges with their visa status and
being able to get the visas that they
need the paperwork they need to be able
to come to the country it will have
impact on the endowment that is still
yet to be understood in relation to the
markets and and it's also possible that
this will continue to impact the gifts
that we receive from our donors because
the magnitude of the turn is unknown and
will not be known for several months or
even a couple of years we have begun to
make the turn without fully knowing its
magnitude and to begin that turn we have
announced several actions for the coming
year and these were announcements that
were made just over a week and a half
ago
it included a five percent reduction in
spending this is a reduction in the
general account spending that is used to
fund programs across the university and
this five percent reduction will largely
be achieved through other things that we
announced at that same time namely a
pause in hiring through next year with
few exceptions that are permitted or
allowed with with appeal of the provost
or the Dean of Medicine a salary freeze
for the coming year reduced spending on
building projects in which we removed
300 million dollars of capital spending
from projects over the next two years as
well as a reduction in travel and other
discretionary spending for the coming
coming year so that identifies the
actions that we are going to take for
the coming year but then the question is
what happens in that period and beyond
what happens over that period of one to
five years and that is the area in which
there is still a high uncertainty how
steep
the economic downturn how fast or slow
of the recovery be and will that
recovery be a u-shape or a V shape or a
W shape those kinds of the answers to
those kinds of questions will obviously
directly impact our ability to handle
this financial storm how long does the
pandemic last then how quickly is a
treatment or a vaccine identified
because first and foremost this is a
public safety issue a public health
issue with consideration as a priority
given to our faculty staff and students
and so we are trying to manage this at
first and foremost with the fact that
with with the community's health and
well-being in mind how large is the
impact on the endowment which
fundamentally is the core of what we can
afford given the large fraction of our
budget that it provides and how does
that impact get incorporated into the
budget over time that is a question that
we are still seeking to understand the
question that is most often asked of me
and probably most often asked if asked
by many of us is why is it that we can't
just spend more of the endowment to
cover the financial short we have
experienced or may experience in the
coming years why can't we you change the
spending rule so that we can cover
anything that might be needed usual
utilizing the large size of the
endowment to do so I think that's an
interesting question and it's an
important question it's a question that
requires an answer that appreciates the
long term priority that the endowment
provides the long term long time
support that the endowment provides to
the University and so I turn it back to
you Peter somebody who was a Provost for
many years and has been president for
still several more to help us understand
the importance of the endowment in
managing our budgets and finances
great thank you Scott and thank you for
that discussion of our budget so the
question is why can't we spend more from
the endowment it is true I'm asked that
question a lot
it's very important to recognize that
the endowment is not a budget surplus
it's not a rainy day fund what the
endowment is is a collection of gifts a
collection of gifts given to the
university by generous donors mostly
alumni over the course of the
university's history and these gifts are
restricted by the donors and how they
can be used for example there are gifts
for financial aid there are gifts for
professorships there are gifts for
student activities these gifts are
invested and they grow over time based
on a policy that ensures that future
generations have the same financial
resources that we do now not more not
less the same financial resources that
we do now we spend a certain amount from
the endowment every year it's about five
and a quarter percent of the value of
the endowment that's actually a lot of
money this year that's about 1.4 billion
dollars it's more than a third of our
operating budget of the entire
university and if we were to leave out
the medical school it's more than half
of the operating budget for the rest of
the university so to do this year after
year the endowment must grow enough to
make up what we spend for it
I'm sorry enough to make up what we
spend from it
plus inflation see the endowment has to
grow on average the amount we spend plus
inflation so I'll ask the investments
office to give me an estimate of what
will happen to the endowment this year
next year and the following years and
they are expecting the following they
are expecting a recession for some time
and eventually a recovery and when we
look at the amount of the endowment we
can spend based on their predictions we
can compare it to the amount we thought
we could spend before the Cova 19
pandemic and there's a difference a few
years from now we could have 300 to 400
million dollars per year less to spend
than we had originally anticipated and
that's why we're taking the actions that
were taking now to blunt the impact of
this anticipated drop in funds as Scott
described this is the term that we are
anticipating well in advance of making
it and so it's the budgetary framework
within which we are working well keep
the community updated as the financial
picture becomes clearer and clearer
let's turn though now to questions about
the future including the fall semester
Scott I'd like to ask you to frame that
issue as well thanks though as the
community knows I started as Provost on
January 1st 2020 and this was not
particularly good timing on my part I
had been in the job just over two months
when the pandemic yet I think at that
point had figured out where my office
was and had managed to bring in some of
my books but here we are so in the
course of the first hundred days in the
job and I should say that I've at least
been in the job longer than Nancy has
she started on February 1st so we have
we have learned on
we have done a lot of on-the-job
training during the first hundred days
in this role we have moved classes
online we that was an announcement on
March 10th of course these are all
announcements that you and the community
have received we asked the community to
work from home on march 16th we stopped
non non-essential research in
laboratories and libraries we postpone
commencement and reunions we canceled
summer events and travel and extended
the work from home policy through the
end of May just over a week ago the
second half of spring semester 2020 will
be memorable to all of us it was the
semester that we converted from a
residential university to doing online
education it was not perfect but I think
it worked better than many of us
expected we demonstrated it how
resilient this community is and overall
I think it was an impressive it was an
impressive effort I would specifically
wanted to thank the faculty and graduate
students for their hard work in
delivering their courses in a format
that none of us imagined or even
contemplated as the semester began this
I mentioned I'm sure that I am probably
not the only one who is managing the
demands of a child in a house as you
consider how you have juggled the
various pressures on your time over this
past several weeks I want to thank you I
want to thank the faculty the staff and
the students for their patience in a
learning environment that is very
different than what they imagined when
he started work has changed teaching has
changed critical research has continued
that includes research that's going on
still in our laboratories focused on
koba 19 some of which Nancy described to
you research to expand testing to
engineer increased ventilator capacity
to do clinical studies on drug
treatments that will lessen the symptoms
of this disease and of course the
frontline doctors nurses and patients
facing staff who are heroes in this
pandemic the question all of us want to
know is what happens next the way I
phrase it is what will I do on my second
one-hundred days in the job when will
laboratories be reactivated for
non-covered research when will the
library be of open again so that we can
do work in the social social sciences
and humanities when will we be able to
go back to work will the university be
open in the fall semester will we be
online or will we welcome students back
to the campus these continue to be
difficult questions and we do not yet
have final answers but we are taking
each of them systematically carefully
expeditiously with input from across the
campus to understand what the next what
the answers to those questions should be
last week President Salva announced a
process for addressing these important
questions that employs six faculty
committees seeking input from over 65
different faculty and additional senior
administrators who have experience from
across the university they will in turn
or our interns still seeking further
consultation from faculty students and
staff to identify what the answers to
these questions should be let me briefly
introduce you to those committees the
work that they're doing
and the way they are approaching their
mandate first and foremost we want to
follow the public health advice and so
the first committee is a public health
advisory committee that provides
guidance for the protocols and
procedures and directions we will follow
as we consider any other action that the
university will take the second is the
research continuity group recognizing
that it will be possible to reactivate
our laboratories and our libraries
before it will be possible to reactivate
the work that goes on in our classrooms
and dining halls this group is defining
how to do safe the labs in the libraries
with clear protocols and standards there
is also an academic continuity community
kanuha t group that is chaired by
pericles louis
pericles will be talking to us about the
details of his work in a minute
but I want to identify what that group
was charged to do one of the challenges
that I have in thinking about the
decision-making process in this is that
there all becomes a question of
probabilities of certain things falling
into line
will there be sufficient testing will
there be sufficient PPE and so to pull
apart that probability question and make
it possible to just clean think clearly
about the possibilities in front of us
we have asked one of the subcommittee's
under academic continuity to think about
the question what is the best version of
an online education that we can provide
recognizing that we now have several
months to prepare for it if that's what
we end up needing to do in the fall so
that's the thinking of one group there
is also a second group that is thinking
about the question what is the best
version of a safe residential in person
education that we can provide in the
fall recognizing that we will be under
constraints for public health
considerations those two considerations
those two groups thinking in parallel
with each other we think will be a defy
the best possible version of what
eventually becomes our decision for the
fall semester
there are also there's also a group
considering what are we doing in the
creative practice specifically around
the arts for example this represents
particularly new and different questions
different than what's being considered
in the other two groups how do you
social the distance of play or how do
you socially distance an orchestra so
what it means to bring the arts groups
reactivate the arts groups is an
important question all of this will be
informed by a group that's thinking
about operations how do we reimagine
work how do we reimagine teaching and
research and this group has
considerations from human resources
facilities IT and hospitality of course
we need to make an answer soon and the
sooner we can make an answer the better
it will be for our community as you plan
for what will happen in coming days
weeks and months we are committed to
making a we are committed to giving an
answer for what we'll have
in the fall semester no later than early
July so this will be approximately two
months from now as we giving us
approximately two months to then make
final plans for what the fall semester
will look like with those committees at
work I should say that they are working
incredibly hard they have made major
time commitments to get this work done
and I am very impressed with the
deliberations that they are already
making but of course we all want to know
the answer to the questions that they've
been tasked to answer Peter so I think
we should turn to Pericles and ask him
to tell us a little bit particularly
about the work of his committee and what
it is planning with respect to the
educational mission of the University
thank you Peter and Scott Yale of course
has been educating young people for
service for 319 years the educational
mission of the university is paramount
second only to the health and safety of
our staff our faculty and our students
and we need to be prepared to continue
this mission in the fall semester
like many peer colleges and universities
we're looking at two main scenarios for
planning purposes and we'll probably
wind up with a hybrid of the two if we
are unable to come together in person in
the fall we will provide remote or
online options that's in a sense
scenario one we realize that this is not
ideal I've been a professor at Yale for
22 years and I know that nobody comes
here in order to take online courses or
you know you want to be here in order to
meet the faculty and interact with your
peers but we know that some students
including some international students or
those with health health issues or are
those otherwise unable to travel may not
be able to make it to New Haven in time
for the start of classes and there's the
risk of a second wave of infection that
might delay in-person opening so we're
preparing for the online possibility our
faculty and staff work very hard over
spring break
to get the spring semester courses up
and running online in an emergency
situation there were challenges but as
Scott mentioned I think the outcome was
better than many of us had expected we
now have the summer ahead of us to make
sure that we provide this form of
education even more efficiently and
effectively and this means improvements
in technology course - and course design
so I'm grateful to staff and faculty are
working together to prepare more
effective online and remote versions of
courses for the Fall
should they be necessary the second
option of course is to meet in person
and if the public health conditions
warranted we'll be providing that
in-person education including
residential and extracurricular life at
Spring Break we had to close down the
residential colleges and some other
facilities very very quickly the
reopening is likely to be more gradual
and we'll need time to be prepared for
evolving circumstances and also for any
public health conditions such as social
distancing and so on that may be
necessary even if we are back here in
person together there's a lot of
uncertainty but our goal has been to
make the campus ready for students to
return sometime in the fall as early as
possible in the fall
initially this may be in smaller groups
and we may have some hybrid of in-person
and online teaching it won't be exactly
the same in the graduate and
professional schools as it is in the
college we're looking at safe ways of
housing students including providing
facilities for quarantine and for self
isolation enabling contact tracing in
case there's a second wave of infection
and of course being prepared to treat
anyone who falls ill we plan to keep the
campus informed as as this discussion
proceeds and we'll provide more detail
in early summer I realize that it's
frustrating not to be able to give a
detailed account of each of these
scenarios at the moment but we actually
have we've been sort of trying to plan
out all the various options and
recognizing the complexity of the
problem and we want to present the
president and the provost with an
adequate map for making this decision
now Peter and Scott and I and all of our
faculty and staff are committed to
Yale's educational mission it's never
been more important than it is now
Yale has been through many crises in its
history
this is as far as I'm concerned this is
the biggest crisis I've ever seen and I
imagine it's the biggest crisis that
many of us have ever encountered but
we're a strong community and I think we
will come through this and ensure that
all Yale students get an excellent
education in the years to come so thank
you Peter and stop right thank you very
much Pericles Kim I want to throw this
back to you in your role as vice
president for university life what
concerns have your team been working on
in preparing for especially in this
context of so much uncertainty
so what I was saying was that one of the
things our staff hears a lot about are
people feeling a loss of people in place
because we're all scattered all over New
Haven all over the state many of us or
the country and the world and we miss
people talk about missing interacting
with their colleagues and their
classmates pursuing their working
activities and actually physically being
on campus and in New Haven and zoom
sometimes just doesn't do it for
everybody I know for my for me I'm
missing Trey and Jennifer and Felix in
the custodial staff and SSS come in or
like many of you I'm tired of my own
cooking I wouldn't mind going to a
dining hall at the moment going to
Berklee College which I go to a lot and
seeing the net and having a good meal or
even walking around the grounds the
facilities so lovingly it prepares
around this time of year so I know most
of you are missing being here physically
but we have to sustain a sense of
community and we have a lot of staff
we're working very hard to do that we
recognize and hear about challenges and
certainly we've all talked about the
fact that people have concerns about
child care about the internet
connections that they have for
themselves and their children
and of course the need to support
faculty sorry faculty and family members
who are sick or who may have lost jobs
so we continue to support them as well
and we're paying particular attention to
in particular mental health and
well-being we have a lot of colleagues
around the university who are working
very hard to support the community on
that the being well at Yale program
which supports staff and faculty has
been putting a lot of its program
online and they report there are
increased numbers of people dropping in
to the meditation sessions and also to
stretching exercise classes which is
good to hear we continue to support
students who might have needs from
mental health and counseling and and
that particular program has been
receiving 700 calls with students over
the over the every week so they're being
really helpful to make sure the students
are dealing with whatever anxiety or
other issues they have as they complete
their term now we recognize that there
are other kinds of challenges that are
being exacerbated by this particular
health crisis Dean Brown mentioned one
of them Koba 19 is is affecting
different populations differently based
on race and socioeconomic status as she
mentioned including here in New Haven
we're conscious of that as it plays out
in the community the campus community as
well and of course there is news
nationally of the rise and racial
discrimination around Asia for against
Asians and Asian Americans and we want
people to know that we have resources
available to support people because we
really want to support those who are
facing harassment and discrimination so
we have a team of people around the
university who are working very hard to
make sure that the community is taken
care of and that we can connect with
each other I encourage you all all of us
to support each other as we go through
this process of trying to not only
continue to flatten a curve but also to
prepare to turn the corner that both you
and Scott have described great thank you
very much Kim Kim Nancy Scott pericles i
want to thank you all for what you're
doing for our community Kim I'd be
interested in hearing some of the
questions that you've been collecting
from participants so why don't we turn
to those questions now so a lot of
people that have submitted questions so
thank you everybody the first question
is for Nancy Nancy the question you're
being asked is when faculty students and
staff returned to campus what would we
do to reduce the possible transmission
of kovat 19 in terms of cleaning
social distancing PPE and the light
thank you for the year question yeah so
first I would say we will adhere to
current state and city guidelines at the
time that we reopen and these in turn
will depend on the prevalence of
infection at that time and so we may
need to make changes as the
characteristics of the epidemic and that
guidance changes I'd say social
distancing is the fundamental strategy
and it's going to include modifying our
physical spaces and our movement
patterns so that we increase distances
in the classrooms and our labs you know
our offices the dining halls are common
spaces in the dorms depending on the
guidance and prevalence of infection we
may need to require masks and we may
need to limit large gatherings our
colleagues and environmental health
services are already developing plans
for enhanced cleaning through the school
on the dirt dorms Yale Health as you
know offers testing and contact tracing
for individuals who develop symptoms and
I think it's going to be very important
that we facilitate the ability of our
students and our faculty and staff to
self isolate and also to obtain medical
care as needed and of course we've
already developed the systems to do this
for our healthcare workers over the last
several months Thank You Nancy we have a
lot of questions related to research so
Scott I'll ask you when do you think
research labs will open and how can you
open them safely yeah it's a great
question like most of the people that
asked that question it's a question I'd
like to know the answer to because I
like others I'm a faculty member who has
a research lab whose work was suspended
we had just received a new federal grant
to do work that we were excited to
perform but in order to follow Public
Health guidelines that work has stopped
and the lab has been been cleared but of
course we like others are anxious to get
that work started again
but we need you to do it in a safe way
and that's not and it's not just work in
laboratories it's also work that's done
in libraries with collections and access
to the various and amazing resources
that are available to the to the faculty
staff and students at the University
it's important that we move carefully
safely and within Public Health the
guidelines that Nancy just described and
also in compliance with government
policy I was interesting interested to
hear that
governor Lamont emphasized that
university researchers one of the
functions that you would like to see
reopen soon we expect we will be able to
reactivate research labs and in the
libraries before we have students in the
classrooms and the dining halls as I
mentioned before the densities are lower
it's easier to socially distance it's
often the case that personal protective
equipment is worn in these spaces
particularly in the laboratories and so
we anticipate that it will be able to
something that we can do before the fall
semester and hopefully substantially
sooner than that as I described there
are research continuity committees being
chaired by Mike rare and Susan Gibbons
and their deliberations have gone on for
about almost two weeks and we expect the
report or it will be completed and
released in the next week or two they
have worked very hard and very
effectively let's be clear that this
will not be an immediate return to work
and the work that we're doing will not
look like it did when we were working in
those phases in February after that
report is released that guidance is
released each research group will need
to consider how their operation can be
achieved within the safe and operational
operational requirements of the phased
reactivation that will be described in
this committee report each group will
need to think through those questions
but it's also let's also be clear we
will reactivate our labs and library
soon we will do it safely and we will
follow Public Health guidance and
government recommended
yeah al will return their productivity
thank you Scott
the next set of questions have to do
with financial aid
well financial aid be affected in the
fall and will be all college financial
aid be reevaluated given the economic
circumstances you don't think that's for
you
okay thank you for that question about
financial aid look the university has
taken a substantial financial hit
however and I want to be crystal clear
about this our commitment to our
need-based financial aid policies is
unwavering now students in Yale College
if you're watching if your family
circumstances have changed you should
bring that information to the attention
of the office of undergraduate financial
aid they'll be ready to help you I see
we have a lot of questions very specific
questions from students about lead
policies what's like housing achieving
and storing belongings left on campus
grading in the fall and the like
students I would say that your deans are
all looking at many of these issues and
they will be communicating with you
directly in the weeks and months ahead
so look for those emails you know also
have a lot of questions about
commencement and I want to let you know
that we are definitely going to be
welcoming the class of 2020 back in
person to campus we just don't know
exactly when because we have to wait for
public health guidelines to tell us when
we can invite several thousand people
back to be here for traditional Yale
ceremonies but when we know that we will
let you know and I do want to tell you
that we're going to have all the pomp
and circumstances that you know we
normally would have as a traditional
ceremony but we're also going to
celebrate you twice because we're going
to have a special celebration with
president salivate giving you actually
conferring your degrees in May 18th and
I will send you some more information
about that as well so look forward to
that and we will look for
about welcoming back in person later on
okay I think that's that might be all
the questions I can see okay thank you
can appreciate that
and we appreciate those who sent
questions we know there's others that
are out there and we'll try to answer
them in otherwise so let me conclude by
saying this at Yale we're going to
continue to pursue our mission will be
educating students in the fall we'll be
conducting research more fully as soon
as it is safe to do so our financial
challenges are serious but with your
help and guided by our principles we
could work through them someday we'll
look back on this period and we'll know
that our university emerged from it
stronger and more unified and that
research universities like Yale made
substantial contributions to addressing
this horrible global crisis I want to
thank everyone for what you do and what
you will continue to do for our
community and for joining this
conversation today we'll keep you
updated quite regularly and we'll do
that through email we'll do that through
another town hall that we are going to
schedule most likely for July and we'll
speak more at that time about the fall
semester in the meantime as Kim
suggested at the beginning of this
please visit kovat 19l dot edu Cove in
nineteen eighty you for the latest
information and to keep up with
late-breaking news
please look at Yale today in your
morning email I want to thank everyone
for attending this townhall thank you
for all that you're doing under these
challenging circumstances thank you so
much